MILLER.
LAWRENCE COMES IN THER AVINEN.
THIS LINE
TROCHECK.
>> Tripp: TAR AVINEN TURNS TO
BUY TIME.
BACK TO TONY DEAN ROW.
Shane: TERAVAINEN TO HIS
BUDDY, SEBASTIAN AHO WHO WASTED
YOUNG EMERSON.
1-1.
>> Tripp: AS YOU IPATION.
THE CAROLINA HURRICANES DON'E W
VANCOUVER DEFENSEMAN, AND
ANDREI SVECHNIKOV S IN THE NEUT
ZONE.
IT WILL BE OFF SIDE. TO
PINCH AT PROPER TIMES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE HOPING
AN NHL TEAM -- OH, THAT HIT
COMING HIT THAT SECOND OF TOOK
AT HIS OWN GOALLINE! JACKETS.
>> Shane: YOU MENTIONED A
JORDAN STAAL LINE AND
SPECIFICALLY STEVEN LAWRENCE A
D'ME AND SPACE, I THINK FAVORS
DEFENSIVE BLUE LINNOW IAN COLE
IT IS OUT TO STOP THIS PUCK.
EXTRA IT SINCE WE'RE SO TING AL
WE TALK ABOUT DOING IT RIGHT,
AND THEY SHOULD BE REWARDED A G
ONLY TROCHECK STAYS ON.
>> Trip
WRISTS IT THROUGH.
TO SIMPLIFY, ON BALLY
SPORTS HAS HELP
COMING FROM BRADY SKJEI.
AND HUGHES NICE CHIP FOR MARTIN
TO A SLASHING NIEDERREITER.
MARTINOOK PLAYING GAMES.
>> Shane: WE CAN SAY THEY HAVE
BEEN